It feels like it belongs to someone else
that shield represents a lot
of things to a lot of people
there's no going back
so we're partners co-workers
not necessarily a team, no.
we look damn good though
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
marvel falcon and winter soldier episode 5 trailer
video we only have a couple episodes left and they
are hyping up another big cameo scene for episode
5 so i'll talk about who i think that is if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the episodes i will be doing videos for
loki after this too that'll be premiering later
this year we have marvel's what if tv series
those episodes will also be dropping this summer
but careful for spoilers for everything that's
happened on falcon and winter soldiers so far
if you have not been watching the episodes so
just to explain the cameo scene that the show
runners are hyping up so malcolm spellman who's
the creator of the falcon winter soldier series
is teasing that viewers are going to cry when
this person shows up in episode five and he says
the cameo will be a very grounded existing marvel
comic book character that we have not seen before
that he wants to see cross over with thor now you
can throw all the theories you have about who that
could be like who's a character from marvel comics
that we've never seen before that would work well
with the thor crossover more on that in a second
after we talk about the footage here and some of
the other story lines that they have to pay off
because obviously the cameo seeing this mystery
character that's supposed to show up will be tied
to some of the existing plot lines that they've
set up they need to pay off but the really big
stuff in these new scenes that they're hyping up
or some kind of flag smasher all out attack on an
event that's happening you see those armed forces
in the streets with all their guns trained up on
a building and you see all these remaining flag
smashers who are pulling the same trick as they
did during episode one remember how they used
social media and those message boards for the flag
smasher group to rally support for their cause and
they just had a bunch of random people come for a
meet up they handed out a bunch of masks and they
used them as a distraction while they were pulling
the big bank heist it looks like they're doing
the exact same thing here at whatever big event is
happening this seems like it's associated with the
grc because that's like a big story line that they
haven't completely explained yet or totally paid
off if you're talking to kari the grc is the real
villain of the series but we haven't met anyone
who works for the grc or whoever's in charge of
the grc so right now they feel kind of like a
faceless villain that might have something to do
with what's going on with the power broker as well
they might try to tie those plot lines together
but you see them pass all these masks out and
there are many many people in masks walking down
this spiral staircase it's actually a really cool
looking shot then we also have that new footage
of john walker captain america and falcon both
with the shield throwing it inside whatever this
warehouse is it seems like this is obviously after
what happened at the end of episode 4 where
he went up killing the flag smasher character
in sort of realizing what his power was
now that he's taken the super soldier serum
i think at this point people have re-watched the
episode enough times that we're all on board with
him having taken the serum like at some point
after he has this conversation with battlestar
here about whether or not they would take the
serum you know hypothetically would you take the
serum if you could in battle starts like hell yes
i would take it i think the whole reason for that
conversation is to basically validate what john
walker was thinking in his head like i should
probably take this right shouldn't i take it and
then battlestar said that so he's like yeah i'll
definitely take it so at some point between this
and their attack on the flag smashers he's taken
it so i think a lot of these moments during his
fight here like where you see him bend the metal
pipe and you see him kind of fighting here but it
doesn't seem like he knows what his full strength
is like he throws the shield and it really
gets embedded in that stone wall i think all
these different moments for him at the end of the
episode is him slowly realizing what his power is
by the end of the episode when he actually winds
up killing that flag smasher it's sort of the
darker version of the very beginning of the
first captain america movie where he's running
after the hydra agent who's just killed erskine
and he doesn't realize what his strength is so he
winds up fumbling while he's running because he's
running so fast only because it's john walker and
he's like this rage monster he metaphorically
hulks out as he's going after all these black
smashers like that's it like after a battle star
dies he just completely loses it no holding back
obviously this is meant to be a very horrific
scene the way this goes down like he bloodied
captain america shield in a way that you should
not bloody captain america's shield what have you
done to this symbol of hope i think they did too
much early on in the early episodes to hype him up
as being really awesome with the shield i
think it would have been a better contrast if
he wasn't quite so strong before he got the super
soldier serum so that it was more evident when he
actually did take it but i think by the time we
get to the events of episode 5 he's definitely
realized like oh no i'm super strong so we'll
see way more of him just hulking out on everyone
then we have the later footage of what seems like
falcon getting the shield back from john walker
captain america at some point training with it
down at his family's home in louisiana bucky
helping him learn how to use it properly so that
it returns to him when he throws it the reason
why falcon's able to do that without having the
super soldier serum is because the shield itself
is made of vibranium it's incredibly lightweight
so almost anybody could throw the shield it's
just that you have to have the skill to throw
it the correct way so that it comes back to you
the reason why it seems like it's so heavy is just
because super soldiers like now knew john walker
captain america and steve rogers captain america
when they're throwing it when they're using it to
attack people they're putting so much force behind
their strikes that it seems like it's really heavy
they have that funny scene with them just
continuing to joke about each other not being
friends like uh we're more like co-workers yeah
co-workers that's the one everybody remembers
thor ragnarok it's okay we know each other he's
a friend from work the funny story about that
line too is that it wasn't in the original script
they were filming the scenes of thor vs hulk in
the contest of champions and someone's kid was
visiting the set that day like a little kid and
he was standing near the producers taika watchiti
while they were getting ready for another scene
and he pointed at the hulk and thor and said their
friends from work and the producers taika loved
that idea so much that they wrote it into the
movie right there on the set which is actually
a pretty common thing them adding little lines
of dialogue and ad-libs to big movie scripts big
marvel movies all the time while they're filming
the most famous example of that recently was iron
man during avengers end game saying i am iron man
when he snapped the infinity gauntlet that was not
in the script when they first shot the scene but
the editor was putting the rough cut together
that part of the movie later and thought wouldn't
it be cool if iron man said i am iron man after
thanos says i am inevitable and they kind of had
to talk robert downey jr into it just a little bit
but he came around and was like okay i'll say the
line so they re-shot his part of the scene there
with him saying the line and it wound up being
so iconic that now you can't imagine him not
saying the line but we still have io and the door
milaje who are after baron zemo so they're not
completely gone from the series yet there's also
the idea of what's happening with thunderbolt ross
the thunderbolts because they're supposed to be
setting that up with this series and what happens
with kari after the events of this series what
happens to dark captain america john walker after
he loses the shield in the title they still have
to pay off the power broker and they still have to
pay off the isaiah bradley storyline because that
seems like it's going to be a big part of falcon
deciding that he will become the next captain
america and will take up the shield also a lot
of people wondering what happens with falcon and
winter soldier right after the events of this
series like where do they show up next which
marvel movies will they be crossing over into
before avengers 5 because it's going to be a long
time before they do avengers 5. as far as falcon
and winter soldier season 2 kevin feige has only
said that they didn't develop season 1 thinking
that there would be a season 2 but they're always
flexible on that and because some of the marvel
series have been such big hits so far like Wandavision was such a big hit now they've started
to talk about possibly doing that but the whole
idea is that some of these series will only be one
season some of them will be multiple seasons like
loki is the first series that i know of that they
developed a season two for early on i don't know
when loki season 2 is going to happen but they
are making it and then there's black panther too
there's so much black panther crossover the black
panther flashbacks for bucky's character will he
also cameo during black panther 2 because they're
filming that movie this summer like really really
soon so just in terms of that secret cameo that
the showrunner malcolm spellman was talking about
a character very grounded in marvel comics history
before he was hyping up the big thor crossover i
was assuming that it was going to be a flashback
for young isaiah bradley and they were going to
pay off that scene where he was talking about
kicking winter soldier's ass back in the 1950s
during the korean war because wouldn't it be
awesome to see the young version of isaiah bradley
captain america ripping winter soldier's arm right
out of its socket just like io metaphorically
and literally disarmed him like a ninja i would
love to see an old man captain america chris evans
cameo but the way chris evans was talking about it
he didn't have plans to show up and they haven't
been hyping him up for a big cameo scene during
falcon and winter soldier but they did secretly
tease that he retired to nick fury's space station
back in episode one so i feel like they wouldn't
have said that if they weren't intending on having
some follow-up moment i don't know if he'll cameo
but i have a feeling they'll try to pay that off a
little bit better i would love to see old man
captain america steve rogers cross over with
present-day thor just to tease him about wielding
the hammer again because he would still be worthy
he'd still be able to wield the hammer if there
was one available even though obviously in present
day before the events of thor 4 love and thunder
the hammer has still been destroyed there was
actually some footage from the set of thor 4 while
they were filming with natalie portman's character
that basically explained where the hammer comes
from like how it gets remade during the events of
the movie i don't want to talk too much about that
because it's super spoilery but if there's more
footage later on i'll do a separate video about
that but the way they'll explain it when they
get to that movie is that mjolnir the one that was
destroyed by hella will basically reforge itself
it'll bring itself back together using odin's
magic it'll be a little bit of a twist on the idea
of odin's enchantment but he who is worthy wield
the power of thor so apparently odin's enchantment
was not also destroyed when hella just physically
broke the hammer but just in terms of where some
of these characters head next is thunderbolt
ross starts putting the thunderbolts together
and instead of killing off john walker they put
him on the thunderbolts team and just give him
a different name like he becomes us agent from
the comics so current mcu thunderbolts dream team
right now is that you have thunderbolt ross being
their darker version of nick fury putting the team
together like we all expect but you have baron
zemo leading the team you have taskmaster and
yelnobilova black widow from the black widow
movie agatha harkness from one division even
though she might not join the team i would love to
see her come back for thunderbolts just to see her
interact with those other characters dark captain
america john walker u.s agent whatever they want
to call him maybe they give him the black version
of his costume from the comics the abomination
from incredible hulk he's actually going to be
part of the she-hulk series early next year when
they air those episodes maybe the leader from the
incredible hulk as well the leader is still alive
he's sitting in the raft somewhere so they could
always bring him back justin hammer from the iron
man movies i'm actually hoping that he comes back
for the armor war series next year too then the
ghost from ant-man and the wasp but you have to
remember it's kind of like marvel suicide squad
so they kill off members all the time to cycle
the roster i know a lot of people are wondering
if thunderbolt ross is going to wind up being
the power broker if sharon carter is secretly
going to wind up being the power broker we'll see
i think we'll have enough evidence before episode
6 if they don't completely explain everything
during episode 5. but post all your theories
in the comments below i'll do more bonus videos
during the week there's a whole bunch of marvel
stuff happening so leave all your video requests
in the comments below everyone click here for my
full falcon and winter soldier episode 4 video
and click here for my marvel loki trailer and
easter eggs video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!